what's a zit I say is it  I'm not allowed to talk to you she live  I wish I didn't know you  but I do  I don't matter what I do I can't save  you tomorrow at the beach we die within  five minutes along with every other  soldier  I'm a soldier I'm not walking away come  find me when you wake up on your feet  maggot what day is it for you  Judgment Day you do know what's  happening to me what happened to you  happened to me I had the power to reset  the day I lost it how do I control it  you have to die every day I'm not a  soldier of course you know you're a  weapon  no matter what we do no matter how  carefully we plan as far as you ever  make it why does it matter what happens  to me why do you care  any times we Vinnie  how many times  for me it's been an eternity edge of  tomorrow  rated pg-13 experience in an IMAX 3d  June 6th